happy Tuesday
all right it's December 6th you know
what that means National miners day
the guys that work underground not the
other kind of miners so put your pants
back on CNN
have you heard the Glorious news make a
wish finally got wind of Jimmy's story
and is giving him a makeover dreams
really do come true
[Laughter]
what Rodeo Cloud did you service to get
that shirt
so anyway we can answer that later but
also big news disgraced attorney Michael
avenatti has been sentenced to 14 years
in prison for embezzling millions of
dollars
they feel strongly
yeah guys slimier than Ebola okra with a
side of slugs embezzling of course means
stealing if you do it while wearing a
suit tie and one of those sexy shirt
garters
yeah
thank God I worked out for the photo
shoot
in addition to the 14 years behind bars
avenatti will also have to pay almost 11
million bucks in restitution to four
clients and the IRS
restitution sounds like when I pay women
to take a nap with me
[Laughter]
oh stop it
I know I know I know where did he come
up with that one huh
this new sentence is separate from the
one he's currently serving which is five
years for trying to extort money from
Nike and also stealing Stormy Daniels
hard-earned cash right from under her
Double D's
otherwise known as Silicon Valley
yep he snatched 300 Grand from a book
advance from Daniels
guess I should have chose a better verb
there but anyway
the cash taken from stormy however was
easy to trace since it was all one
dollar bills
[Laughter]
avenatti will start serving those 14
years after he finishes that term and by
then I'll be 60.
now for those of you too young to
remember avenatti became quite the
liberal hero you know like a tax
collector or a doctor who gives sex
changes to kids it happened when he took
on President Trump by sidling up next to
Stormy Daniels rump poor thing she
thought avenatti was going to help her
but instead he screwed her
something she'd normally get paid for
but
in this case it was the reverse and the
media they couldn't get enough of
avenatti in that slick skull of his
handicapped by their own biases and poor
judgment remember all this nonsense you
got lucky tonight we're back with
attorney Michael avenatti he is a main
player to me you're like the Holy Spirit
you are all places at all times he's out
there saving the country look I can
think you're doing a hell of a job I
don't think you're in this for money
looking at the 2020. one reason why I'm
taking you seriously as a contender is
because of your presence on cable news
hahaha
I like that sack of eyeballs in the back
of my fridge that didn't age well no
wonder CNN gave Brian stelter his
Walking Papers
oh whatever it takes to get him to
exercise
that was mean
but this whole avenatti Scandal bolsters
arguments you've come to hear a lot from
this show first I always say never date
a stripper and not just because it's
your stepmom
but also that the media happily chases
any shiny ball placed in front of them
as long as the shiny ball indulge
indulges their assumptions in this case
it was all about evil Trump avenatti
capitalized on their Trump derangement
and wrote it like a drugstore donkey
into any left-wing wet dream Factory
that would have him
but the good news it's yet another media
narrative falling apart the news builds
stories like their house of cards and as
time flies by it creates a gust of wind
which blows their houses over and some
take more time than others you got
former president Trump's nuclear secrets
that turned up in a cardboard box in
Mar-A-Lago that ended up being
memorabilia so that story went away
faster than the polyester rash on
Jimmy's chest
they accuse Trump of what the rosenbergs
were executed for but no correction
necessary I'm thinking the media's
gotten more people killed than cats
cooking
turns out crypto King Sam bankman freed
was more like klepto king after it was
discovered he was using clients funds
allegedly to backstop losses at another
business he founded but like avenatti
riding again on trumped Arrangement
creepy Sam wrote in on virtue signaling
another scam the media swallows like a
pound of sardines during feeding time at
this View
oh my God
and where did all that money go houses
swimming pools drugs he certainly didn't
use client money for a haircut and
breast reduction
[Laughter]
here's what happens when you mate Mark
Cuban with a toilet brush
it's uncanny I suppose it's a
coincidence he was the top Democrat
donor and he hasn't been arrested yet
like it's a coincidence that holiday
parties end when Brian Kilmeade shows up
we're also learning a whole lot about
how the media and the government
colluded to subverted election through
social media
despite what the media said Hunter's
laptop is as real as my gorgeous
hairless pecs
point is I'm going to tell you what you
already know whatever the mainstream
media backs runs screaming from it like
you just saw Anna Navarro in a three-way
mirror
and whatever they tell you you know it
isn't true take it with a grain of salt
like when I promise my interns a bonus
it's on them for believing me and the
next time the mainstream media tries to
sell you something like a charismatic
lawyer fighting for the underdog keep
walking because unlike you their
memories are shorter than our presidents
they think you're stupid and lazy and
boy if that's not the pot calling the
kettle a person of color
[Laughter]
oh Wonder no one trusts them anymore and
that's why this Christmas so many of
them are getting a severance package
along with a lump of coal
[Applause]
conversation with we'll be right back
anchor of the story Martha McCallum
and just like the World Cup he leaves
people disappointed HOSA Fox Across
America Jimmy fala
[Applause]
his journalistic skills gave liberals
the chills author of so you've been sent
to diversity training Chadwick Moore
and her Christmas stocking still has a
foot in it Fox News contributor Kat Tim
foreign
Martha you've been reporting the news
for quite a while he's been a straight
shooter I believe you were the first
show I was ever on when I came to Fox
and then during that show for all of
this yeah it was that it was something
called the it wasn't about it didn't
have the name the desk the live desk was
right over there yeah it was right over
there and you had everybody seated
around the live desk and as the show
started right somebody tapped me on my
shoulder and asked me to leave
I got bumped because some big story
happened and they pulled me away they
said get the loser off the set oh that
was my first appearance when I moved
here from New York City I was a little
kid in a big city barely 20. that was a
long time ago so you're probably
following a car around my fan
we gotta go yes so is it a weird that
here's an entity the media that's
supposed to shine alive on on Truth or
exposed truth fell for this and you bet
I mean I I I I I don't mean to sound
like you've been around forever but you
you've seen this a lot what is the what
is their weakness what is it
you know he was uh exactly what you said
he was promising them the goods on Trump
he had Stormy Daniels by his side and
the disgusting thing is that he ripped
her he promised her right that he was
going to make make it all right by her
that Trump was going to pay her money
while he was stealing from her book
Advance amazing and then she ended up
that you know it fell apart in the
courts the Trump case and the decision
was that she had to pay Trump three
hundred thousand dollars in the end it's
amazing so I mean he has to be besides
the fact that he is disingenuous and
slimy as you said and now is like crying
in a courtroom saying please you know
see all the good things that I've done
in my life and they're like well on the
good and evil Ledger you got a long way
to go buddy
um so he's you know he's trying to find
some some mediation in all of this but
it is absolutely repulsive how that when
I watched that that uh piece of video
that you guys strung together the Holy
Spirit yes YouTube of the United States
yeah my God what a mess yeah it's
incredible Jimmy so you are not alone in
stealing from sex workers
no I'm just saying that that's what he
did with Stormy Daniels oh that's funny
well my outfit has nothing to do with
sex workers no it's anti-sex working no
I was like I'm a best no one will sleep
with you in that shirt that's not true
I'm a western guy growing up we love to
play a game called Cowboy I can't
believe a Miller's Outpost is still
around
that one crushed
going growing up in the backyard we love
to play this game called Cowboys and
Elizabeth Warren's and uh
Greg nice when in doubt Red made it out
exactly stick with me okay because
there's a couple of things here okay
okay the fact that he was being touted
by stelter is my favorite thing in the
world as a presidential Contender yes
that that's how boundless their
desperation was to stop Trump okay
history will show he never wrote in the
presidential limo but he did make the
license plate yeah
nice but back to what Martha was saying
and what you were saying okay is
everybody now that we're a little
removed from the situation you realize
they were the crazier entity in all of
this because anybody could be the hero
of the day even if they were the villain
yesterday exactly Let me Give an example
Michael Cohen right he was Trump's fixer
if the tanning bed broke he'd fix the
bulbs or whatever he was doing yes and
he was like literally Hitler like you
know what I'm saying and then he was
like he left the Trump World and became
a contributor yeah like the next day is
if it didn't happen the day before yeah
and that's what's so laughable about it
yeah and the avenatti confession if you
saw it in court is my favorite thing
like Stormy Daniels thought it was bad
acting yeah come on man I've seen a
better plot in naughty nurses five you
know what I mean yeah so that's but you
know what that's an underrated version
of naughty nurses one of the rare
instances where the sequels are better
than the originals I know I know
R.I.P naughty nurses so uh Chad Wick um
do you think it's poor reasoning or is
it uh that causes their misdiagnosis or
is it their politics
well I think what makes it so
frustrating is there's no accountability
and they don't even care yes and they
don't even double down when they make
mistakes because it would kind of be
respectable yeah but they were like
screw you we love him yeah but instead
they're just like nope that never
happened moving on yeah it makes it even
more slimy they don't regret they don't
regret they forget instead of regret and
I wish I was like that and I think that
does something internally when you live
your life like that when you're never
honest and always have to keep running
from your mistakes I think that's why
the other way they are I think they're
also so separated from their customers
they know that no one's ever going to
question them yeah I will have to say
I'm gonna miss Michael's uh I won't say
coked up I'll say high octane late night
DMS that you would send me angry about
things which I found to be kind of a
lovable figure after a little while I
mean I think the Sam bankman freed guy
yeah did a lot more damage than this guy
did yeah maybe so but uh so cat uh what
do you make of this how do you feel what
do you think Stormy Daniels is doing
right now
probably learned some lessons
I can't believe all these people are
just running around trusting other
people I know I used to do that
uh I used to
I used to think you could trust someone
like as long as you know they knew that
you know you had something on them that
you could destroy them right turns out
that doesn't matter
um I used to think you could trust
yourself that's not true either you know
I don't know we just just stop trusting
just stop trusting because you never
know it could be this guy and even in
you know maybe if you're not a lot of
people would want to be this guy because
they just haven't been given that kind
of opportunity to screw someone over you
know that's an upbeat message cat thank
you Merry Christmas
I'm just getting into the holiday spirit
that is so good no it's true I said
wasn't it Ronald Reagan who once said
trust but verify let's talk about his
wife
that is so I went with it it's too
lovely marriage he thought because he
got that he could get away with it
because everybody loved him but it turns
out being famous can help you with a lot
of things doing crimes not one of them
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else